et sur son compte instagram on a
retrouvé des photos d'elle à l'époque où
on n'était pas route mais il ya surtout
une polémique les chéris avec cette
phrase qu'elle assortit maeva cook
regarder voilà cette polémique
les shérifs on l'a retrouvé un bien sûr
avec crinière de lionne voilà regarder
si je dois vous donner des raisons de
voter pour moi ce soir je dirais ma
sympathie bienveillance ma détermination
et puis après une miss france blonde une
brune une à la crinière de lionne
pourquoi pas une rousse alors grignard
de l'yonne style aussi alors crinière de
baye cheikh est ce que ça a choqué
quelqu'un parce que sur les raisons qui
comme d'habitude
est ce que ça vous a sauté que tenir de
l'yonne non mais nous non ici qu'ils
sachent ok mais non mais attendez
messieurs c'est de la démence quoi on
peut pas dire que ça c'est chaud
crinière de lionne ça c'est dit de tout
temps de paris où paris du boulevard
dans les années ben on en a plus
d'ailleurs mais mieux qu'ailleurs de
l'yonne voilà on n'a pas la bagnole la
ville
non c'est inadmissible je vais prendre
et comme par hasard la blonde la brune
et une miss à la crinière de lionne donc
la femme noire c'est un animal
les mandats à l'époque de la
colonisation moi je comprends pas genre
bad crinière de lionne c'est un
compliment annoncé sur quel ingénieur de
bien tu vas voir ça devait être contente
vous avez une première bien tenir doha
on peut alors là oui moi ma femme elle
est métis elle a une crinière de lionne
je me réveille tous les matins à côté
d'elle ça me choque pas rien à voir non
mais gilles tu vas vraiment trop loin
écoute je suis noir je suis pas bon un
petit sociale super talent est là c'est
pour en parler et même dans les années
90 aller chez le coiffeur demandé une
coupe à la lionne mais ça a toujours été
une fois la lionne sinon oui très bien
ce qu'ils râlent parlement qui sont les
gens qui disent ah mais moi je rage les
genres aura sur twitter sur twitter que
l'estomac est un truc donc frais vers le
mans et gel tarifaire le monde d'accord
les cotisations de polémiques du nil et
tout le temps extrêmement limité sur du
vide et en fait moi je veux bien qu'on
fustige les personnes racistes ou les
intentions à 6 il faut faire attention à
l'intention tu penses rue marc cette
nana là à la td elle était raciste elle
critiqué les personnes réagissent
vivement faut détendre l'atmosphère si
laura pouvait revenir chercher sa botte
à la primature a écrémé haqqani
fondateur vite elle a perdu chez moi ça
me dépasse et est ce qui m'a amusé par
contre c'est que dans le parisien où la
parisienne qui dépend du parisien
regardez ce qui est marqué pour
qualifier la nouvelle miss france ça ta
crinière flamboyante n'est sans doute
pas étranger à la victoire on parlait de
larousse la wii est donc là ça n'a
choqué personne arrêtée par le mal
partout quand même la réponse de miss
france